in their different ways two of this
week's biggest news stories shone a
spotlight on how the swamp really works
the Iran nuclear deal and Michael
Cohen's deals with some of the world's
biggest corporations we get to the
bottom of it all in tonight's swamp
watch Britain France and Germany lobbied
furiously to try and stop President
Trump ditching the disastrous Iran
nuclear deal and now they're trying to
keep it alive
of course they dress it up as high
principle but the truth is that for them
it's about more money for their big
business cronies yes the swamp is truly
global Britain has pushed numerous
business interest in Iran since the
Obama deal lifted sanctions including
their telecoms company Vodafone
partnering with Iranian internet firm
high web to help modernize its network
and in 2017 British officials agreed to
seven hundred and twenty million dollar
deal to create a solar energy park in
Iran with investors from Asia Europe and
the Middle East Germany is even more
swampy after sanctions were lifted car
maker Volkswagen reached an agreement
with Iran's Mamet khodro to sell two of
their models there and German
manufacturing giant Siemens signed a
contract worth at least 1.5 billion
euros to build rail coaches and upgrade
train tracks in Iran but here's the
swampy astir Minh and this is truly
shocking one of the biggest impacts of
new sanctions would be on energy and
Russia in particular giant Russian state
oil and gas companies Rosneft and
Gazprom both have interests in Iran
guess who is now head of the executive
board at Rosneft and also chairman of
the board of directors at Nordstrom - a
subsidiary of Gazprom Gerhard schröder
Angela Merkel's predecessor as
Chancellor of Germany the former German
leader is on the board of Russia's
biggest energy companies since Russia's
got practically no economy apart from
energy that's basically like being on
the board of Russia and the elites
accuse Donald Trump of collusion but
perhaps the country deepest in the Iran
swamp is France in December 2016 French
airplane manufacturer Airbus signed a
deal with Iran air to select a hundred
planes for around 19 billion dollars
another French aircraft maker ATR struck
at 536 million dollar deal
with iran air for 20 planes french oil
giant total si signed a 20-year five
billion dollar contract with Iran and a
Chinese oil company to develop an
Iranian natural gas field and French
carmaker Peugeot got a deal to open an
Iranian plant producing two hundred
thousand vehicles a year it turns out
that 1/5 of pojos entire global market
is in Iran and you'll also be interested
to discover that the former Rothschild
banker who once worked on a bailout of
Peugeot is none other than a manual
macron now president of France I think
would all take these globalist elite
politicians a bit more seriously when
they condemn Donald Trump for pulling
out of the nuclear deal if they
themselves weren't up to their necks in
their own swamp deals with Iran
now the other story this week that's
putting the swamp in the spotlight is
the influence peddling of Donald Trump's
former fixer Michael Cohen international
drug giant Novartis confirmed that it
paid Cohen 1.2 million dollars for a
consulting contract an employee inside
Novartis told stat news that Cohen
reached out to Novartis is then CEO in
early 2017 promising access to the
president and the most influential
officials in the new administration
Novartis of course reportedly jumped at
the offer it's exactly the kind of
corruption these pharmaceutical
companies engaged in all the time so
they can keep ripping you off with
higher drug prices
Novartis spent over eight million
dollars lobbying the US government just
last year they spent over forty five
million lobbying since 2012 and three
quarters of the lobbyists that Novartis
hide in 2017
had previously held government jobs
including former Senate Majority Leader
and presidential candidate Bob Dole and
former House Ways and Means Committee
member Jim McCreary just in case they're
lobbying doesn't buy them enough
influence Novartis has also donated over
one hundred and sixty eight thousand
dollars to political candidates just in
the 2018 election cycle and remember
because Michael cone wasn't technically
hired as a lobbyist but as a consultant
Novartis didn't even have to disclose
its contract with him who knows what
other swampy influence peddlers are
still on Novartis his payroll or the
other drug companies that buy the
outcomes they want from your government
of course Novartis wasn't alone Michael
Cohen all
approach telecoms giant AT&T with a
pay-to-play pitch and they gave him a
$600,000 contract for an inside track to
the new administration to help with
their bid to buy Time Warner
pathetically AT&T CEO Randall Stephenson
tried to blame all this on the guy who
ran his DC operation Bob Quinn who was
thrown under the bus and forced to
retire Stephenson said the hiring
Michael comb was a big mistake yeah
right the only mistake was getting
caught AT&T is infamous for its vast
lobbying and influence buying operation
they spent more than 16 million dollars
on federal lobbying each of the last two
years and as of 2017 86 of their 114
lobbyists had previously held government
jobs in the 2016 election AT&T gave four
point seven million dollars to hundreds
of candidates and groups in both parties
they also donated 1.5 million to the
host committee for the Democratic
convention and 4.2 million dollars to
the Republican convention on top of that
AT&T swampy CEO Randall Stephenson
personally gives thousands of dollars to
DC politicians a thousand to Paul Ryan
2,700 to John McCain 10,000 that at the
National Republican Senatorial Committee
and 33904 the Republican National
Committee not to mention the thousands
of dollars he's donated to his own
company's political action committee
this is the kind of corruption that
Donald Trump was elected to stop and
let's be fair he's already delivered
some of his drain the swamp pledges like
clamping down on the revolving door
between government and lobbying and also
to be fair
Michael Cohen's influence-peddling
didn't work the Trump administration
took AT&T to court to block it's Time
Warner merger but the site of a trump
insider running around pitching himself
to help big corporations even as the new
administration was taking shape is an
insult to every Trump voter just today
The Wall Street Journal is reporting
that Michael Cohen pitched his swampy
services to Ford as well Donald Trump
was elected to be the voice for the
voiceless to help the Forgotten men and
women of America not to help big
business get its way in Washington
what part of drain the swamp did Michael
Cohen not understand pointing this out
is not being disloyal to the president
it's Michael Cohen who's let the
president down by embarrassing him and
undermining one of his most important
promises to the American people Michael
Cohen should apologize pay back his
swamp fees and tell us who else he
pitched it's called
draining the swamp